hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to getting over it with
Bennett foggy this game is gonna be
totally fair not rage-inducing at all
and I'm gonna keep my sanity in this
everything is fine everything is fine
everything is fine
see I'm pretty good at the game okay I'm
free I'm pretty good at the game know
any loss progress is a opportunity to
[Music]
sing but they don't help me I don't want
anything else for Christmas I just want
to get back to where I was and I'll now
believe that you will ever feel better
you're sure to be happy again and
knowing this will make you less
miserable now Abraham Lincoln this game
is fascinating in that it makes me
exceptionally angry but at the same time
it's understandably my fault it's it's
understandable
hi chica would you good puppy what are
you doing
what are you doing
[Music]
[Applause]